la importancia del caballo dentro de la
geopolítica mundial
eso creo que está casi no tiene un punto
de discusión y lo otro lo que para mí
fue transformador fue la frase de
alejando el mango cuántas cosas nos
perdemos en el mundo por no entender
cómo piensan los demás cuando yo comencé
a trabajar con caballos ya de grande
en realidad en esta frase fue lo que a
mí me incentivó a buscar respuestas de
cómo piensa un caballo como pienso un
distinto
y la respuesta que tenía más a mano que
eran relacionada con la cultura con la
tradición de resultar insuficientes
empíricas
al mismo tiempo entonces busqué
respuestas dentro de la ciencia la
etología y descubrí la ecología que la
ciencia que estudia el comportamiento de
los animales
y se me abrió un mundo
y el primer parámetro que tuve en cuenta
fue que tenía que entender como pensaba
en el otro como pensaban los caballos y
ese quiebre fue muy importante para mi
vida porque a mí me puso a prueba qué
tan bueno era yo escuchando a los demás
qué tan bueno era su escuchando los
distintos
y entonces empecé a tomar algunas cosas
algunos puntos de referencia que tenía
la etología de cómo se manejan los
caballos como piensan y empecé a
desarrollar una técnica de amante
natural o domesticar los caballos desde
su lógica y empezar a trabajar con otra
especie pero desde su lógica de
comportamiento
enrollar me fue muy bien a mí me
transformó mucho después yo cuando por
un camino que ni pensaba empezó a venir
casa a la gente a casa a buscar este
tipo de respuestas y este tipo de
herramientas en el primer momento venían
a buscar herramientas para
para avanzar sus caballos para
domesticar sus caballos y cuando yo le
nombraba o les decía mire que vamos a
empezar a trabajar con caballos pero te
el pienso caballo
es trabajar con los caballos pero desde
su lógica esto es como luego estás con
un chico y bueno puedes hablar en tu
incisos e ingeniero no le puedes hablar
en en términos de ingeniero y hablamos
en contarle cómo es la ecuación para
sacar el peso específico de una torre
por ejemplo tengo la llama de entonces
empezaron a entender y empezó a venir
gente de casa a trabajar con caballos de
esta manera y como yo ya tenía esta
experiencia de transformarme o de que
los caballos que fueron transformando yo
les advierto cuidado
un caballo de estado mando tranquilo
porque te corre de eje
entonces cuando vienen a casa por
ejemplo no suelen tomar en este momento
porque es una charla de 15 16 minutos
voy a tomar para explicarles algunos
puntos de la etología que alguien me
llevaron a trabajar con caballos los
caballos
son una especie que están regida por el
miedo son presa de depredadores y su
instinto de huida está regido por el
miedo de pekín en sí una especie que
vive cuando habla de caballos hablo de
caballos en estado salvaje pero funciona
así
en su cerebro en el hemisferio derecho
del caballo se aloja el miedo y en el
hemisferio izquierdo se aloja la
confianza
transformar el miedo en confianza es el
trabajo de que entra de quién maneja
caballos desde su lógica es cómo llevar
a un chico a vacunarse y llevarlo de la
mano y el chico en la primera vacuna va
a protestar de la segunda menos y una
tercera y contracciones grandes
variables para ir solo a vacunarse ese
camino de transitar de transformar el
miedo en confianza es un es un camino a
no mucho para recorrerlo
cuando viene gente a trabajar en este
caso anna empezamos a trabajar con los
miedos anna me cuenta quizá también
tenía este parecido con los caballos y
que tenía miedos entonces digo mira
vamos a trabajar con un caballo con
ciruja es un caballo que también tiene
miedo y sus miedos son
a pasar cualquier palo que tienen en el
piso o cualquier palo que se asemeje a
una valla y él tiene ese miedo bosco
entendés
mi miedo es cambiar de profesión porque
estoy trabajando en un lugar
que no quiero estar
y luego ver cómo vamos a trabajar con
una base de confianza yo también te voy
a ser como quien lleva al niño de la
mano a vacunar a los dos y después ver
tener que hacer con cirujano entonces
hicimos este trabajo y yo le puse este
ejemplo después el caballo la valla y
ella le dio mira
tu miedo
es atravesar la valla
la vida que uno quiere
está después del miedo
la vida que vos tenés en la que estás
teniendo ahora
si los dos potencian y se pueden generar
confianza
pueden atravesar ese miedo bueno la
historia de esta experiencia de anaco
nunca vayan fue fantástico porque se
dibuja pudo pasar las vainas
y hoy anna está trabajando en más de
plata con caballos que la su pasión
otra característica de la manada es que
los caballos necesitan
inevitablemente alguien en quien confiar
para que suceda lo que les acabo de
contar resido
los caballos viven en manadas son
gregarios cada uno cumple un papel
social si se quiere dentro de la manada
y no creo que le puede hacer le puede
pasar a un caballo es quedarse solo y
siempre necesitan alguien en quien
confiaba en las manadas hay líderes y
jefes generalmente los líderes de la
manada son hembras son siguas porque
porque dentro de la manada las yeguas
permanecen y manteniendo crías y los
machos son renovados por macho más
jóvenes que se dedican a reproducir la
manada y los machos más viejas son
expulsados y quieran los más jóvenes
generalmente se da a este parejo de
liderazgo dentro de la manada en este
tema que le estoy contando
qué quiere decir que hay un jefe y hay
un líder
y cuando digo juan
que están viendo en foto elevado de la
empresa y cuando se le cuento a esto es
más de agregó vos tenés que diferenciar
para trabajar con caballos que es un
líder y que es un jefe el líder convence
el jefe manda
y se quedó pensando y yo lo que estamos
haciendo notas mentales
mi segunda es que hice lo que me pasa
bien la empresa
soy dueño de la empresa pero mis
empleados no tienen no tienen confianza
en mí entonces hicimos un trabajo de
acercamiento con sol que se puede probar
lo árabe digo mira para generar el
primer vínculo de confianza tenés que
tener una posición humilde jamás
encuentras en tu cuerpo y ver si viene
porque las mejores relaciones con
caballos con la familia con los hijos o
lo que sea se dan en libertad si vos
tenés una posición wilder seguramente
que va a venir bueno esta es la foto de
él agachado y el caballo acercándose
bueno el pudo salir desde quema de
empresas pudo delegar y a partir de una
experiencia bueno él pudo delegar yo
puede estar detectando su vida
trabajando por distintas partes del
mundo
otro otro punto para tener en cuenta es
este el bien común
los caballos dicho humanamente piensan
en el bien común es una frase por ahí
muy humanizada pero es para que le
entiendan a ver aquí en la pampa tenemos
grandes extensiones de tierra
en el oeste es muy común en otra campo
de cuatro mil y cinco mil y seis mil
diez mil hectáreas manada de salvar de
caballos sueltos semisalvajes y es muy
muy habitual que se han desplegado por
los pumas en la manada cuando matan a la
manada y cuando nosotros vamos a buscar
la manada siempre encontramos muerto el
potrillo
no encontramos la madre
junto con el potrillo
para nuestra especie para nuestro
esquema de pensamiento es muy loco
pensar que la madre de hondón es dijo
y eso hay especies que son diferentes
qué piensan diferentes
entonces digo la manada de caballo
piensa en el bien común
cuando el vino o richard que se están
viendo trabajar con los caballos en el
medio entiende esta historia del bien
común de los de los caballos
y él también hace como una analogía con
su comportamiento y mis hijos así que a
mí también me cuesta es todo bien común
está bueno
porque así se manejan las palabras es
tan bueno pensar en el otro
sí porque va al mundial eso pudo ser el
otro es verdad y me cuesta mucho esto el
bien común empezamos a hablar y él me
cuenta que es único hijo
bienvenida del ambiente
la cata
se debe contar esta película porque la
vida a los únicos hijos nos cuesta esto
es compartir somos muy muy de edad pero
compartir tranquilo tranqui
entonces o bienvenido al club y vamos a
hacer un trabajo de trabajo que hacemos
con ciruja
range al estar en el medio le digo
tienes que ponerle sacar un bozal a un
caballo y ponérselo a otro pero esta
orden este trabajo no tenés que
compartir y delegar el trabajo que
nosotros hacemos con ciruja y con
richard y dos más
richard ahí funciona como un cerebro
donde da las órdenes a su hemisferio
izquierdo en su hemisferio derecho
cada uno de los que no pueden hablar
entre ellos los hemisferios y él tiene
que delegar la información cuando pasa
por esta experiencia de caballos equidad
el estudio de richard que trabajan
en la plata tiene un estudio de gráfica
y hace dos años que tiene un ver entero
y le atiende 80 chicos es una historia
que a mí me conmovió muchísimo
y me hizo ver que los caballos pueden ir
por este camino de transformación
otro punto que yo tomo de la manada
decir este es el espacio los caballos
tienen
un valor superlativo del espacio son el
aspecto del espacio uno del otro
inclusive en situaciones críticas
una manada en estampida a ver
aquí en el pampa o en argentina es muy
común en la tradición ver
la suelta de tropillas son imaginense no
quiero extenderme pero imagínense son
500 caballos encerrado buscando cada uno
de sus iguales porque quedaron apartados
y salen 400 500 camas o corriendo sala
veloz en esa situación crítica
de caballo corriendo en esta entidad no
se conoce que un caballo haya pasado por
encima otro son tan respetuosos del
espacio del otro ante situaciones
límites
en este caso vino irene a trabajar con
caballos
el problema que ella tenía era
gran madraza
una gran madraza que invadía el espacio
de su hija su hija ya pasada de 18 años
19 y no podía decir su carrera porque
porque cada decisión que tomaba la hija
de irene irene decidía cómo cuándo y
cómo debería ser lo que se decidía
cuando hablamos este tema de espacio
ella lo entendió perfectamente hicimos
un trabajo
digo te vas a acercar a caballo desde él
es un trabajo que hacemos generalmente
con aproximación de potros luego puedes
entrar al espacio de él siempre y cuando
él te lo permita en el momento que vos a
ingresar al espacio de él él se va a
desplazar y su vice entonces vos tenés
que delimitar cuál es el espacio del
caballo para que no se vaya en el
momento que este espacio ha respetado
esta línea yo cuando lo respetas el
espacio del otro y saber cuál es el
límite se genera un grado de confianza
es más si eso se reitera el respeto y
confianza
bueno con este trabajo irene lo que
puedo hacer es liberar a su hija su hija
hoy está haciendo un máster de
comunicación de barcelona hace dos años
y nada tiene una relación muy feliz con
su vida
y esto es casi
lo más importante para trabajar con
caballos lo que yo he aprendido para
entrar en este mundo del pienso a
caballo los caballos tienen un lenguaje
de hace muchísimos años mil millones de
años que es el mismo es el lenguaje
corporal
a los caballos les cuesta empatizar con
nosotros porque nuestro lenguaje es muy
complicado para ellos decimos una cosa
decimos una cosa pensamos otra
emocionalmente por ahí sentimos algo y
la compartimos con con alguien o vemos o
elegimos con quién compartir
pero hay una sola verdad nuestro cuerpo
habla
imagínense que cuando uno se propone
frente a un caballo y el caballo es
experto en el lenguaje corporal nos lee
inmediatamente las emociones o todo lo
que nosotros tenemos dentro
entonces a un caballo no se le puede
medir
porque te lee tener en tu cuerpo tener
las emociones porque el cuerpo habla
hay un caso que yo les quiero contar
que es casi revelador muchos de ustedes
deben conocer historias de caballos que
son muy malos vayan con todo lo han
escuchado historias de caballos muy
malos pero que con los chicos no
con los chicos pasan cosas diferentes
que con los chicos causa un humano capaz
que el patio 1 patio 2 y otros y seca
por el niño
y hay una relación hermosa y es
precisamente por esto por lo que hablaba
recién los caballos en el interior y los
chicos a esta edad 34 años
tienen el alma limpia vienen con el
disco rígido sano
no hay forma que un caballo pueda tener
mala intención con un niño
entonces en este punto son un día me
pare digo realmente
qué función cumplen los caballos en la
historia en esta era que estamos
viviendo así
no hay guerras a las que ir no hay
países para conquistar a caballo
y digo cuál es la función
y empecé a hacer un remember de mi vida
y todo lo que he pasado con caballos
y digo tal vez este para esto para
mostrarnos que podemos entrar al mundo
del pienso caballo pensando como ellos
para tener ítems para transformar
nuestra vida nuestro comportamiento y
ser mejores personas pero digo hay 2
dos puertas para entrar en este mundo
del pienso trabajo una es la que les
acabo de contar con los casos de ana
irene richard juan con los caballos
y la otra es esta
la de guardiola esos niños
es la puerta más pura
en esta imagen
levanten la mano los invito a que no les
gustaría volver a andar en bicicleta
otra base a quién no le gustaría andar
en bicicleta para volver a su opinión
volver a andar en bicicleta o esto o
remontar volver a remontar un barrilete
esta es la puerta
volver a ser niños volver a estar en el
presente
volverá a sentir que lo único que
importa es
es esto
pensar limpio pensar en el futuro
y volverás amigos para entrar en el
mundo de piensa parar
a mí los caballos
dentro informadora vida bien cambiado
suba muchos no los conozco no lo
conoceré
pero les voy a dejar un gran deseo
desde alejandro magno
que intenten conocer cómo piensan los
demás
que uno aprende del distinto del que
piensa distinto el mundo se cambió de
gente que piensa distinto mahatma gandhi
cristo maría teresa de calcuta la gente
que piensa distinta es la que movió el
mundo
entonces mi gran deseo es
y ojalá se encuentren con un distinto
y de esta manera puedan ingresar como
listos op al mundo del pienso caballo
salud de buena vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]